good morning we're going fishing today
and we're going fishing for chuna long
from chuna hopefully we'll get a yellow
f as well but we'll see we're going to
pick up Dad Ross and then we'll be on
our way we're going to Cape Town all
right early
morning oh thank you so much we St for
some much needed coffee it's still
pretty dark
out Coffey
yes and we are
here a little bit Misty a little bit
cloudy all right guys so we're going to
go with hoooked on Africa that's Sean
and his crew and we're going to see if
we can get some
Tunas this is it good morning good
morning good morning good morning how
are you good good here we are Nikita you
ready for this I'm ready for the big
ones that Rose you ready I'm ready look
at these
[Music]
rods so we've been uh driving for about
an hour and the water temperature is a
lot
higher as you can see
there just above
17°
the coming
in there
the all right so this is quite special
because we got a big troller here and
he's bringing in the Nets and what that
creates is a lot of birds as you can see
in the sky who is just feeding on some
of this stuff here and then hopefully
some chuna
see the hike coming
up oh yeah CH Chum there goes some of
the
chum now we want to attract The Fish
Feeding on dead fish
there quite exciting Nikita yeah it
is here we go
[Music]
all right we gave it a try here didn't
get anything we're just going to troll
the area to see if we
can get any of
them
sorry oh no problem so fish on keep the
[Applause]
[Music]
pressure it's happening guys we are on
here with a fish Ross is on with a
tuna hold
it keep reing real real real real real
keep the
line still
there keep the
L
it
feel
good small winds small
winds and halfway
halfway at the same time we're trying to
get more fish yeah cling okay we fishing
around here hopefully yes coming to bite
we'll hook more that's what we that's
how it works yeah not how it would work
that's the theory
okay if we were fishing a competition I
wouldn't be allowed to touch
your this
is all the way from the
US I mean you can real trying to
read if I could figure this out I'm
starting to get it I think yeah yes yes
get it get it oh man ah so I think we
got a big one we're taking our time we
don't want to lose it but keeping the
line
tight a he's behind the engine
now off
theore that's a another one that's it
okay and again okay that's what you
going to get
so the tactic is is you don't use your
own power to drill in these fish you use
the swell to your
advantage it's big is it
big it's big oh you've been playing it
for almost 10 minutes
now b
r heavy like a
best it's about those big bass you cat
in the
US go there we go we're winning we're
winning we winning we winning we
winning this is an African fish it's not
American fish
yes done well
done are you getting tired no he's fine
that's
good little by
little
he was
going he's getting closer slowly but
surely okay half a one that's
him
e
Ross your first big junah yeah in
the then maybe we need to bring it to
the front ready I
just that was a tough fish this one got
to move
him
yes
there you
go very nice when you dressed by a 60y
old man
yeah that's
funny yeah only inch by
inch done any go well done well done
well done thought bad be your second
time in this in the
ocean see the bird oh yeah
so you see what they're doing is while
Ross is fighting this fish they're also
throwing Chum in so preparing it here
that side as well so they're trying to
get some more tuna while we fight this
one you see they got a problem with
these Birds because whenever they throw
the chum in and even the hooks the birds
come and take
it
yeah it's all good yeah it's quite heavy
heavy he's a big boy oh
yeah he going to be so
worth that's a yellow City on the water
look how pretty it is that one Atlantic
yellow gray head yellow be
nice hey if you tell your birders back
home you saw Landing yellow no they'd
also be
impressed he been over 15 minutes now he
has some fight left and again go Ross go
got him he's coming he's coming he C
giving up this is is and again no
experience like
this so when a yellow funa comes closer
to the boat they go in circles and then
all you can do is just take them in
little by little walk in the walk the
go you need h no no just
put
yeah real real
real you don't need to go to the gym you
can just do
this you can sleep on Sunday on the
airplane not that there we go lot of
sleeping 40 40 hour flight you can sleep
then more passion more passion more
energy more
energy singing
there's your one there's your one there
you go there you go there you go coming
to leader good South African fishy
welcome to South Africa Le on the real
please right when we go we got to go
let's go Ross let's go let's
go just L here on the top and you can
see here the fish is getting close
seeing some
color
again
you stop you going to
stoping nice
fish come real let real R it's
real and
again again hand G yeah got what side
you want
meel wow
yes that is a massive
know that is
huge so I wrestled the steer before you
got it but this is amazing keep watching
keep watching keep watching look there
here he
comes they can't get him in too
[Applause]
big what do you think H welcome to EA
yes holy cow there we
go high
five lot fish that's that's a lot of
fish okay
Nikita the bar pretty high there yeah
you did you have to go high you have to
go
higher you're
up your arms um feeling it feeling it
wait for
tomorrow you've been fighting that one
for over 20
minutes that's insane but what's really
important to us is that we we show some
respect to this fish really beautiful
fish um going to wash it down take some
pictures put it on ice just look after
it and I just some guys catch it leave
it on the deck and just it's a beautiful
fish so we showed respect we have a good
fight all
[Music]
[Applause]
right nick.com let's go let's go we're
just taking photos and then that one
went so that's how quick things going to
happen where's your back back
thing
and Nik is
on how's it feeling Nik nice I want you
to square up okay want to come back here
so just come come with me here we go
come back this one okay perfect just
keep the you the but fish will come
around keep feeling
bring it back here all
good how's the feeling
aming that
big good perfect inch by
in ladies always Ang
don't so that is number two on the line
okay
w
got starting to cool it's starting to
cool it's not so big
huh not that big
but what are you say it doesn't feel
that
big Bal is starting to pull
huh's one's one one come on onita come
on this a big one and chasing the birds
away guys AR even scared of the birds
oh what's wrong Nikita huh he's fighting
a bit now big one oh this fish wasn't
big
now B it's
fting come
on
okay getting really
hot coming up on 10
[Music]
minutes come onik one come well done
well done that's it think of your
brother s
this one's for
you relax
relax ler Nikita ler
ler I'm totally hooked on Africa
do you think it's going to be bigger
than yours Ross I think it's going to be
bigger than mine she's got she's got the
skill you know what Ross c a fish of
aive yeah he doesn't really matter this
fish he the fish of aive I
did unbeli compar compared to those
Bassy catches back
home second second trip to the ocean
second trip to the ocean yeah and a big
fish like that tonle yesterday that's
special and he thought that was
special bring him in bring him in
Nita come on Nikita this is this is a
good
spot
[Music]
almost look how
right yeah M ain't going no it take your
time not too much
time
one I need
one theer
Hallelujah when I tell you to stop
winding you just Mo to the
back see color yeah seeing the color
color it's looking
beautiful oh it's a nice
fish
what what we do now is we we Notch the
notch the skull expose the spine okay to
to kill the fish as quickly as possible
okay here we go and we take this stay
this your Rod we're going to go down the
spine and by
n that was quick
[Music]
easy well done thank you well
done it's okay good
nice well doneita
awesome that's your biggest fish it's my
biggest
fish okay we need to get another one
five it up yes well
[Music]
done well
done good you got a big one got a big
one well done both of you got got a nice
one yeah B bomb that's awesome now we
only need to see if I can get one yeah
you're going to get the Grandpa's
Grandpa
beish strong
Daniel woohoo woo fish
on
okay there's a smaller one is a
long
long smaller than the other one but
still really nice fish
so you guys can see we're right behind
the stroller and when it's processing
all the fish it comes out here on the
side and then uh you might get a tune or
two as
well so that's the
idea see the door the doorway
everything's coming out
yeah morning you copy
Captain yeah I just wanted to find out
to me you uh so what time will you be
pulling your net again
other all right okay thanks very much
for that y we got a couple of nice fish
behind you when you pulled it last time
so I was just wondering uh if you're
still going to be in the area thanks
very much for coming in appreciate it
okay Lu thanks very much back Channel 16
anymore it's 11 1 2:00
perfect
that is is interesting
so the boat just started pulling in the
Nets so that
means the birds are going to increase
and also maybe a few Juna to see what we
can get that's what we're hoping for
yeah make
sleeping
ah
the net hold hold the top up B it on the
bottom and these two black things on the
doors that hold the net apart
okay
so and now it's a Feeding Frenzy the
birds and also seals and underneath fish
that you can't
see there's more tuna they'll take the
lures come
on that R go they've got two
on
woo and it's starting to
rain woo at the same
[Music]
time there we go that's
a good thank you
high five high
five beautiful
fish two more Nikita two more how was
that that was awesome quick first of
excitement
yes now they're cleaning the deck and
we're moving
forward oh there we go another one this
time is Nikita
oh
losted sorry
Nikita the crew is working really hard
to get us some fish it's quite nice here
actually you can uh go to the toilet if
you go down there there's a nice toilet
where we can sit down for ladies and
then there's some snacks over here over
here there we
go Nikita is on and it's
raining Nikita
my hand is slipping from the
rain this your best you get
it it's coming in right here what's the
L what's the rod
J there we
go in the rain this is fishing so there
were these birds called staris we call
them right and
um they saw them flying around here and
then we went just to see what they're
looking at and there you go we got some
Longs there we
go this one feels nice woo oh man is so
much fun this one is
bigger show us oh yeah W look at him go
woo Daniel yeah it's a nice
one now the thing is you have to guide
it a little bit here with your with your
uh hand thumb with your thumb
yeah so it doesn't wind up in the same
spot
oh like that the leaders
in come on Daniel bring it bring it
bring it
oh look at this
[Music]
guy what a beauty thank you guys so much
cool cool Co d d thank you that's half
course hit the road you guys Happy
perfect good out OFA that one pulled
really hard I thought I was a yellow fan
and it was a long F but that was so much
fun my goodness woo high five Daniel
high five three yes 3 three
three so what we're going to do now is
we're going to head back um the weather
is changing here a little bit and um it
is getting late so we're going to head
back and we're going to make some
sashimi and some sushi with these
tuna
sorry sorry we've been driving for a
while but
uh still got some some ways to
go we're going really fast now just to
see if we can get in front of the
container
ship all
right there it
goes made
it
there we
go all
good all right R land again
good
now this is what you call
fishing if you want to have an awesome
time catching tuna here in South Africa
booked on Africa I'll add all the
details for you in the video description
down
below and can you can you hold this one
on us
yeah take
photo okay there we
[Music]
go water
when they
swim these are all St they come out when
they when they like flat they lie in the
groove there yeah so they actually
little a
ples doing their thing that's awesome is
very cool beautifully designed so they
say they're going to take away the fish
and they're going to prepare them for us
but look we've got a visitor who wants
to steal our fish if you want to go I'll
show you where all
right
6.5
wow this one that's the biggest one
that's the biggest one
yeah 76
kilog that's a fat that's yours that is
a big
boy that's a lot of meat and it will
keep you fed for a few months and it's
it's so rare to find this good quality
meat this is top
brain yeah they just brought us the nice
tuna steak right here so we're going to
dig in they're going to bring us some
tuna Simi and Sushi as well in just a
minute and uh we're excited guys we're
going to dig in here we're going to
start eating
thank you this looks so
good
soft
M
good so this chuna steak is sesame seed
and then here we just got some normal
[Music]
ones
thank
[Music]
you oh my goodness he can't get pressure
than this right from the
[Music]
ocean good
Daniel and this is tuna fishing in South
Africa please remember to subscribe and
we'll join you in the next video bye
like